This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Sam and I'm Georgina.
In this program, we'll take a look at the sensitive issue of sexual violence.
At the start of the decade, no one knew that the two word phrase
Me Too would go viral or spread quickly and widely on the internet through social media.
But when explosive allegations against Hollywood movie producer Harvey Weinstein
made headlines in 2017, the Me Too hashtag became the focus for a global movement of women
determined to expose the truth about abusive sexual behaviour. Weinstein was found guilty
and given a 23-year prison sentence. But the deeper reasons behind the problem
in America and worldwide have not disappeared. I have a question now about the origin of the Me Too
expression. Although the Me Too message went viral due to public support from famous Hollywood
actresses, the phrase itself was thought up years earlier by a civil rights activist to run a
book. What year did she first use it? Was it A, 1996, B, 2006, or C, 2016?
I'll guess B, 2006. Okay Georgina, we'll come back to that later. Now more about Toronto
Burke. Yes, Toronto worked with marginalized women in neglected American communities,
shocking numbers of whom were victims of sexual violence and abuse. Here she is talking
with the BBC World Services Program Hard Talk about how the Me Too movement continues to speak up
for voiceless women and girls. The beauty I think and the magic of Me Too is that it's a
unifier in that way and it's where survivors find community and so definitely the mainstream media
kept the focus on the actresses and Hollywood and that but at its core the women who came forward
were really no different than those girls who I served in the communities 10 years before.
Toronto doesn't call the girls and women who were abused victims. Instead she prefers the term
survivors, people who are able to carry on with their life successfully despite very unpleasant
experiences which still affect them. The Me Too movement went viral when several famous movie
actresses came forward offered to give information about sexual harassment. While these Hollywood actresses
were famous celebrities most survivors of sexual violence are ordinary women, living ordinary lives.
That's why Toronto calls the Me Too movement a unifier, something that unites and brings people
together in this case women of different race and social background. But while the media focused
on particular people, Weinstein and several actresses in the movie industry, Toronto is clear that
the problem is bigger than just individual cases. Here she is explaining about the wider reasons behind
the Me Too movement. We can talk about Harvey Weinstein at nauseam but we also have to talk about
what are the structures that were in place that allowed a Harvey Weinstein to thrive. If you're
going to talk about Harvey Weinstein being successful then we have to also talk about capitalism,
right? Because it's the it's the love of money and the desire for people to have money and what
he represented. The bottom line is people value those things more than they value the humanity of
the women that he was destroying their lives. It's about power and it's about privilege. At the end
of the day these are the two things that we have to talk about dismantling. According to Toronto,
the behavior of abusers like Weinstein was not challenged or questioned because of their privilege.
Power and advantage held by a small group of people, usually because of their high social position,
or because they are rich. So rather than focusing on individual cases,
it's male dominated social structures like privilege that need dismantling,
breaking up or being stopped from working by gradually reducing its power over a period of time.
Toronto knows the problem won't disappear overnight, but she believes the Me Too movement has opened
up a space to talk about sexual violence in a new way and set out a pathway forward.
Let's go back to the quiz question. I asked you what year the two-word expression Me Too was used.
Was it A1996, B2006 or C2016 and you said? Yes, I said it was B2006.
Well done, Latina, you are absolutely right. Today we've been talking about the hashtag Me Too
movement which went viral in 2017, meaning it spread quickly on the internet.
The name Me Too was created by Terana Burke, an activist who works with sexual abuse survivors.
People who experience abuse but are able to carry on with their lives successfully.
In 2017, many of these survivors came forward, offered to give information about sexual harassment
in Hollywood. And these actresses were supported by millions of women and men across the world,
making the Me Too movement an important cultural unifier, something that unites and brings people
together. Now the movement wants to shift the focus away from individual cases and onto social
structures of privilege, power and advantage held by a small group of people, usually because
of their wealth or high social class. And according to Terana, it is these social structures and
attitudes which need to be dismantled, stop from working by gradually reducing their power over time.
And that's all we have time for today. Join us again soon here at 6 Minute English for more
Topical Discussion and Recovery. Bye for now. Bye!